mohamad isn't backing down on his prices
the vegetable seller has been arguing
with a customer for 15 minutes every bit
of money he earns counts in these
testing times a shortage of US dollars
which the local currency is pegged to
means a larger number of migrant workers
like Muhammad are unable to transfer
money home to their families I can't
send money to Bangladesh I can only
afford to eat and drink $100 is now only
worth 15 this dollar crisis started four
or five months ago and foreign workers
here are suffering it's not just me with
a lack of dollars in the banks and the
Lebanese currencies value on the black
market reduced some employers have been
forced to pay their workers in lira
instead of dollars almost having the
value of their salaries for many migrant
workers in Lebanon sunday is a day of
rest and some of them have come to this
church to pray but they are clearly
concerned as their weekly conversations
have changed from catch ups to financial
problems according to the International
Labour Organisation the average salary
of a domestic worker in Lebanon is less
than 250 dollars a month the financial
downturn has affected us all but foreign
workers are some of the most vulnerable
especially because of a lack of legal
protection with a shortage of dollars
from aren't receiving their salaries and
are defaulting on their rent doubling
the possibility of being exploited
further foreign domestic workers are
excluded from Lebanon's labor laws
instead they're brought in on a
sponsorship system one that some rights
groups say leads to exploitation the
sponsorship system means many foreign
workers are not only exploited in
Lebanon but also that employers or
abusers get away with it without being
punished by law last week New Labour
Minister Lamia mean warned that Lebanese
citizens will need to take on
low-skilled jobs traditionally filled by
migrant workers to cope with the effects
of the economic crisis we contacted the
Ministry of Labour and we're still
waiting for comment on this story
it's still not clear if Lebanon's new
government will reform the labor laws am
I gonna do
let's live near Walmart McKenna this is
the worst I've seen it in the 12 years
I've lived here but only God knows what
the future holds for now foreign workers
like Mohammad have little option here or
back home so hey dad's al-jazeera beetle